Hello everyone,
welcome to the channel and my name is
Paul.
Today's topic is the Scots language.
Scott's is a language spoken in
Scotland,
one of the constituent countries of the
United Kingdom.
Right off the bat,
it's important to point out that there
are essentially three different
languages in Scotland,
Scottish,
English,
Scott's and garlic.
Garlic is a Celtic language that is only
distantly related to English and Scots
as an endo European language.
Scott,
since Scottish,
English on the other hand,
are closely related to each other,
though they're not the same thing.
Scottish English is for the most part
standard English,
but spoken with a Scottish accent.
Scott's on the other hand,
is distinct having diverged from a
dialect of middle English and having
features that differ from English.
Some people consider Scott's to be a
separate language while others consider
it to be a historical dialect of
English,
just like the historical dialects found
in England,
but we'll get into that a little bit
later.
According to the 2011 Scottish census,
just over one point $5 million people
speak.
Scott's around 30 percent of the
Scottish population history.
The roots of Scott's lion,
north Umbria and old English,
one of several old English dialects,
Northumbria and old English was being
spoken by the seventh century in the
Anglo Saxon Kingdom of North Umbria,
which was located in northeastern
England,
and part of the Scottish lowlands.
The Kingdom of Scotland was founded in
the year 8:43
with the unification of the pig dish
people and golic speaking.
Scott's but English speaking.
Northumbria and lance were not yet part
of the kingdom when the northern part of
North Umbria finally became part of
Scotland.
In the 11th century,
Golic became the prestige language of
the area,
but English remained the most widely
spoken language.
The variety of English spoken there may
have been significantly influenced by
norse because the southern part of North
Umbria,
along with much of northern and eastern
England,
had been under Danish control and it's
English.
Dialects had been influenced by norse
and Scandinavian settlers were also
present beyond the border of that area
as well.
In the twelfth and 13th centuries during
the middle English period,
the [inaudible] system of administrative
division led to the spread of English
further into Scotland borrows.
We're autonomous urban communities where
traders,
merchants,
and craftsmen could live and do business
in exchange for paying taxes on their
earnings.
The bureaus were ruled by nobles who
answered to the King.
They attract an economic migrants from
other parts of Scotland,
including golic speaking areas from
England,
especially from areas that had been
under Danish control,
where North's influenced dialects were
spoken and from farther away places like
flenders,
phrygia and Scandinavia.
English became the common language of
the boroughs,
but the multilingual environment created
by the economic migrants had an
influence on the language,
so as English became more widespread in
Scotland because of the boroughs,
it also began to diverged from North
Umbria and middle English.
Other influences were Latin because of
its role as the ecclesiastical and the
language of laws and record keeping and
Norman French because of the influence
of King David.
The first who had close ties with Norman
England.
The divergent variety of middle English
that grew out of these influences is now
referred to as early Scott's,
but at the time it continued to be
referred to as English until the end of
the 15th century.
In the 14th and 15th centuries,
English replaced and garlic and much of
the lowlands as well as replacing French
as the administrative language,
as well as replacing Latin as the
language of records and law.
Another thing that happened in the 15th
century was that the Orkney islands and
the Shetland islands came under Scottish
rule.
Scandinavian settlers had been living on
these islands since the ninth century
and spoke a language called norm that
derived from old norse,
but Scott speaking,
settlers began to move there and the
prestige language became Scott's from
this contact.
New dialects of Scott's would develop
with more influence than other forms of
Scott's.
These dialects are shetland,
Scott's and slash or Kadian,
Scott's or orkney.
By this point,
scots had become fairly distinct from
English as spoken in England.
One thing that set them apart was that
the southern English dialect of London
was becoming the standard in England,
whereas Scott's had more in common with
the northern dialects.
Another thing that set them apart was
the great vowel shift.
The great vowels shift took place
between the years 13,
15 and 1600 more or less and caused
vowels of English to be pronounced
differently.
This also affected Scott's,
although the specific changes we're
different and some vowels that changed
in English remained unchanged.
In Scott's,
for example,
in middle English,
the letters,
Oh,
you represented the sound uhhh in
southern English,
and thus in standard English,
this sounds shifted to our,
but in Scott's,
it remained unchanged.
So today in standard English you say
mouse,
but in Scott's you say Moose and a brown
cow and English is a Brune coup in scots
who knew broom?
The great vowel shifts took place at
about the same time that English
orthography was becoming standardized,
so that English spelling often reflected
earlier middle English pronunciation,
and it still does today.
Scott's on the other hand,
was written more freely to reflect the
way it was really pronounced.
An extensive body of Scott's literature
was written in the 15th and 16th
centuries,
but towards the end of that time period,
as English was growing in prestige,
Scott's was increasingly being written
using a combination of scots and
English.